un nouveau quartier va naître à tour le
quartier de rochepinard hier monsieur
dubois chabert préfet d'indre et loire
jean royer député maire de tours et de
nombreuses personnalités procéder
d'abord à l'inauguration du centre
socioculturel des rives du cher aux
installations ultramodernes
ensuite plusieurs personnalités dont le
député maire exposait devant plans et
maquettes
les raisons de ces nouvelles
constructions ainsi que les projets
futurs pour l'aménagement de la rive
gauche
rappelons que ces projets doivent
comprendre 427 logement divers 550
logements hlm et 90 logements plr ainsi
que de grands espaces verts et terrains
de sport la première pierre d
aménagement rive droite de rochepinard
était ensuite officiellement scellé
concrétisant la naissance effective de
ce grand ensemble